you have all been given some terrible
advice and that advice is this if you
want to stand out look around see where
everybody else is going and then go in
the other direction he says son I'm the
captain of a crab boat my responsibility
is not to get you home alive my
responsibility is to get you home rich
leave motivation whatsit of Tanith
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to not
follow your passion stand out and not
put safety first with micro and my take
on these top 10 rules of success joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't follow your passion in my
opinion you have all been given some
terrible advice and that advice is this
follow your passion every time I watch
the Oscars I cringe with some famous
movie star trophy and hand starts to
deconstruct the secret of their success
it's always the same thing don't let
anyone tell you that you don't have what
it takes kid and the ever-popular
never give up on your dreams look I
understand the importance of persistence
and the value of encouragement but who
tells a stranger to never give up on
their dreams without even knowing what
it is they're dreaming I mean how can
Lady gaga possibly know where your
passion will lead you have these people
never seen American Idol year after year
thousands of aspiring American idols
show up with great expectations only to
learn that they don't possess the skills
they thought they did what's really
amazing though is not their lack of
talent world's full of people who can't
sing it's their genuine shock at being
rejected the incredible realization that
their passion and their ability had
nothing to do with each other look if
we're talking about your hobby by all
means let your passion lead you but when
it comes to making a living it's easy to
forget the dirty truth just because
you're passionate about something
doesn't mean you won't suck at it
and just because you've earned a degree
in your chosen field it doesn't mean
you're going to find your dream job
dream jobs are usually
just that dreams but their imaginary
existence just might keep you from
exploring careers that offer a
legitimate chance to perform meaningful
work and develop a genuine passion for
the job you already have when I was 16 I
wanted to follow in my grandfather's
footsteps he was a skilled tradesman to
build a house without a blueprint that
was my passion and I followed it for
years I took all the shop classes at
school I did all I could to absorb the
knowledge and skill that came so easily
to my granddad unfortunately the handy
gene is recessive it skipped right over
me and I struggled mightily to overcome
my deficiencies but I couldn't I was one
of those contestants on American Idol
who believed his passion was enough to
ensure his success
one day I brought home a sconce I had
made in wood shop looked like a
Paramecium after a heavy sigh my
granddad gave me the best advice I've
ever received he told me Mike you can
still be a tradesman but only if you get
yourself a different kind of toolbox at
the time this felt contrary to
everything I believed about the
importance of passion and persistence
and staying the course but of course he
was right because staying the course
that only makes sense if you're headed
in a sensible direction and while
passion is way too important to be
without it is way too fickle to follow
around which brings us to the final
dirty truth never follow your passion
but always bring it with you rule number
two stand out seeking forgiveness and
not permission typically can be great
advice you had your bets if you play it
safe
you're gonna lost in this giant throng
of other people who are playing it very
very safe and looking into the lens the
very very same way
and saying the same things at the same
time day in and day out so that's a long
way of saying if you're considering
taking a chance in your particular
industry and it differentiates you from
the rest I would take it
I'd call it a reverse commute if you
want to stand out look around see where
everybody else is going and then go in
the other direction rule number three
don't put safety first safety safety
first is me going back to you know OSHA
and PETA and the Humane Society you know
what what if oh should got it wrong I
mean I hope this is heresy what I'm
about to say but what if what if it's
really safety third right
now I mean I mean really what I mean to
say is I value my safety on these crazy
jobs as much as the people that I'm
working with but the ones who really get
it done that they're not out there
talking about safety first they know
that other things come first the
business of doing the work comes first
the business of getting it done and you
know I'll never forget up in the Bering
Sea I was on a crab boat with the
Deadliest Catch guys which I which I
also work on in the first season we're
about a hundred miles off the coast of
Russia 50 foot seas big waves green
water coming over the wheelhouse right
most hazardous environment I'd ever seen
and I was back with a guy lashing the
pots down so I'm 40 feet off the deck
which is like looking down at the top of
your shoe you know and it's doing this
in the ocean unspeakably dangerous I
scamper down I go into the wheelhouse
and I say with some level of you know
incredulity captain OSHA and he says
OSHA ocean and he points out there
but in that moment that what he said
next can't be repeated in the lower 48
it can't be repeated on the factory
floor any construction site but he
looked at me and he said son and he's my
age by the way he calls me son
I love that he says son I'm the captain
of a crab boat my responsibility is not
to get you home alive my responsibility
is to get you home rich you want to get
home alive that's on you and for the
rest of that day safety first
I mean I was like rule number four
follow opportunities
here's another dirty truth your
happiness on the job has very little to
do with the work itself on dirty jobs
I remember a very successful septic tank
cleaner a multi-millionaire who told me
the secret to his success I looked
around to see where everyone else was
headed he said and then I went the
opposite way then I got good at my work
then I began to prosper and then one day
I realized I was passionate about other
people's crap I've heard that same basic
story from welders plumbers carpenters
electricians HVAC professionals hundreds
of other skilled tradesmen who followed
opportunity not passion and prospered as
a result also if you want to learn to
have more self love check out my 254
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below it's good to treat
other people the way you would like to
be treated yourself it's like a golden
rule and there's a reason for it and
that reason is that we're connected I
always did everything back pass half
words you know I like to challenge
myself once you can meet yourself with
compassion then you can begin to let go
of whatever it is that's really with
your mindset you can get back on track
you can refocus and don't wait till
Monday and that's a mistake that
everybody makes rule number five be
realistic people love to say things are
what you make of them when they want to
suggest a level of self empowerment and
I'm all for that but some things are not
what you make of them some things simply
are what they are gravity for instance
is not what you make of it
you know you can be a fan of it or not
you can accept
not but if you lean back too far you're
going to fall down it's a little naive
in my opinion to go through life with
the attitude that every single thing you
encounter is going to be a reflection of
how you shape it that's just not how it
works
rule number six focus on work ethic your
foundation offers scholarships for a
work ethic that's right
well every foundation I know and every
scholarship I know focuses either on
academic achievement athletic
achievement you know need-based things
talent work ethic by itself is a thing
that nobody really seems to to focus on
so I'm more interested in attendance
records than I am in in you know SAT
scores I was so so we look for kids who
can make a case for themselves show up
early stay late and learn a skill that's
in demand rule number seven fake it til
you make it
thank you till you make it I'm afraid
that's supply two two that I'm actually
behind I have been impersonating a TV
host for all of my career now I've been
honest about it
I've been honest about the fact that I
fake it so I think if you're gonna fake
it till you make it that's great
but you might in the process want to
embrace the level of transparency so you
don't pretend to be not faking it now I
know how counterintuitive that is but
you have to remember that today the
thing that's for sale more than anything
else is authenticity
now you can be authentic without being
correct and you can still be liked as a
result which ultimately confirms the
fact that if you fake it until you make
it you ought to do it in a way that's
completely transparent rule number eight
develop valuable skills there's a ton of
opportunity in the country and in my
humble view of all the divides currently
dividing us the big divide is between
the people who are convinced
opportunities dead and those who are
fairly convinced it's not all over here
and now and I think 5.6 million
available jobs and what's called the
skills gap is proof positive I think the
fact is 75% of those jobs don't require
four-year degrees for the proof positive
and I would further posit that 1.3
trillion dollars of existing student
loans on the
other end of things might suggest that
we've been letting money we don't have
to get to can't pay it back that you
came for jobs don't exist every time I
have this conversation what comes back
over the net is your ante college we're
worse you're anti education so if I
could look earnestly into the camera and
just say for a moment there is no hope
without education you have to have some
sort of useful skill but this idea that
the only place to get the best education
is the most expensive place yeah it's
killing us
rule number nine have a mission I have
formed a theory I'm gonna share it now
in my remaining two minutes and 30
seconds it goes like this we've declared
war on work as a society all of us it's
a civil war that's a cold war really we
didn't we didn't set out to do it and we
didn't twist our mustache in some
Machiavellian way but we've done it and
we have waged this war on at least four
fronts certainly in Hollywood the way we
portray working people on TV it's
laughable if there's a plumber he's 300
pounds and he's got a giant butt crack
admit it you've seen him it all the time
that's what plumbers look like right we
turn them into heroes where we turn them
into punchlines that's what TV does we
try hard on dirty jobs not to do that
which is why I do the work and I don't
cheat but we've waged this war on
Madison Avenue I mean so many of the
commercials that come out there in the
way of a message what's really being
said your life would be better if you
could work a little less if you didn't
have to work so hard if you got home a
little earlier if you could retire a
little faster if you could punch out a
little sooner it's all it's all in there
over and over again and again Washington
I can't even begin to talk about the
deals and policies in place that affect
the bottom line reality of the available
jobs cuz I don't really know I just know
that that's a font in this war and right
here guys Silicon Valley I mean how many
people have an iPhone on them right now
how many people have their blackberries
on we're plugged in we're connected I
would never suggest for a second that
something bad has come out of the tech
revolution good grief not to this crowd
but I would suggest that innovation
without imitation there's a complete
waste of time and nobody celebrates
imitation the way Dirty Jobs guys know
it has to be done your iPhone without
those people making the same interface
the same circuitry the same board over
and over all that you know that's what
makes it equally as possible is the
genius that goes inside of it so we've
got this new toolbox
you know our tools today don't look like
shovels and picks they look like the
stuff we walk around with and so the
collective effect of all of that has
been this marginalization of lots and
lots of jobs and I realized you know
probably too late in this game I hope
not cuz I don't know if I can do 200
more of these things but we're gonna do
as many as we can and to me the most
important thing to know and to really
come face to face with is the fact that
I got it wrong about a lot of things
we're thinking by we I mean me that that
the thing to do is to talk about a PR
campaign for work manual labor
skilled labor somebody needs to be out
there talking about the Forgotten
benefits I'm talking about grandfather
stuff the stuff a lot of us probably
grow up with but we've kind of kind of
you know kind of lost a little barack
wants to create two and a half million
jobs the infrastructure is a huge deal
this war on work that I suppose exists
has casualties like any other war the
infrastructure is the first one
declining trade school enrollments are
the second one every single year fewer
electricians fewer carpenters fewer
plumbers fewer welders fewer pipe
fitters fewer steamfitters the
infrastructure jobs that everybody is
talking about creating are those guys
the ones that have been in decline over
and over meanwhile we got two trillion
dollars at a minimum according to the
American Society of Civil Engineers that
we need to expend to even make a dent in
the infrastructure which is currently
rated at a d-minus so if I were running
for anything
and I'm not I would simply say that the
jobs we hope to make and the jobs we
hope to create aren't gonna stick unless
they're jobs that people want and I know
the point of this conference is to
celebrate things that are near and dear
to us but I also know that clean and
dirty aren't opposites they're two sides
of the same coin and you'll number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is do the hard work better charge
every snake we want to let her get is
away from the water if possible a little
more cuz they're quick she can turn
around and beer in that water then we're
pretty much out of luck so we're pretty
much in luck if it goes away it doesn't
then I'm out of luck all right here we
go three two
it hurts this is the part where you tell
me it's not venomous right she'll like
go see this kind of maybe if you like go
overhead just go ahead let go let go let
go your hand there you go that's a good
one Mike yeah that's a very good one now
you can wear the badge of honor
I knew somewhere you'd have a tattoo I'm
gonna need one of those now I have a
special bonus cut from Mike on how to
avoid bad advice that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one what is the hard work you've been
putting off that you just need to do
number two what is your mission
number three what valuable skill do you
need to develop and if you promise to
take action after watching this video we
don't just watch videos anymore we do
something after watching them give me a
hash tag believe down the comments make
that promise to yourself and then get to
work the advice you should be most leery
of usually occurs in a in a frame and
those frames usually are hanging on a
wall oftentimes in a conference room and
it says things like teamwork exclamation
point you know there's a picture of a
bunch of people rowing a kayak something
I've worked for persistence you know
there's some guy climbing a giant Mount
you you get the idea once you see advice
in a frame
hanging on a wall be very suspicious
if you want to learn how to outwork
everyone check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you know people talk about working
hard and working smart the answer is
only both man if you had to get up every
single morning remind yourself how hard
you need to work trying to choose a
different profession